hi conan o'brien again
i'm answering a question a week today we
answer the third question the question
is from taylor cobb he asks conan what's
the most grievous wound you've ever
received
wow that's hard to say it's a good
question though
let's go through them uh when i was
about i would say 12 i had an
appendectomy so they sliced me open i'm
going to show you the scar right now
uh
okay that's not the scar that's actually
the line made by my to exist underwear
if you're a lady or a dude
you can seal the deal with two exist
i better get paid for that but
underneath here there's a white line
that's covered i don't know that that's
yeah let's there's hair there this is
getting weird uh there's a white line
that's where they took my appendix out
of my body that was pretty grievous i
think a couple years later summer job uh
i'm wearing shorts i'm late for work my
summer job i got to get there my mom
yells down the stairs scouting
take out the trash
and so i was like oh my she's like take
out the trash so i run i grab two really
heavy trash bags and i'm running out the
front door my house in brookline
massachusetts
and some idiot in my family no one
fessed up to it through a serrated top
from a tuna fish can into a plastic
trash bag it was sticking out the side
like a ninja star i'm walking out the
door it's really heavy one of them goes
chunk into the side of my calf
cuts it open to the bone right there
that's a tuna fish can right there you
could see all the way inside like
pulsing veins bone what did i do
emergency rooms sewed it up then went to
my job and got yelled at for being late
true story
let's flash forward to
this is my senior year in high school i
take a walk in the north end of boston
near the aquarium honest to god
uh
set upon by a gang of youths who didn't
like the ireland t-shirt i was wearing
and uh they demanded 50 cents i've
always been a wise ass i said no they
said why not i said i don't feel like it
before i knew what happened i'd been hit
like five times really fast here in the
nose
they all laughed ran away i went to the
emergency room
and my nose was completely crushed to a
pulp
and my mother shows up the same mother
who a few years earlier had said take
out the trash and she shows up and she
says how's my boy is his nose broken
this is exactly what the doctor said he
was british and he said broken good god
it's a bag of bone situation
honest to god true story
uh
also broke my elbow when i was wrestling
a kid i was in a cast for a long time
and i ate a lot of cheese popcorn back
then it was my favorite food and the
cast went up to here when they cut the
cast off and broke it open six weeks
later moldy cheese popcorn
that had fallen down into the cast
spilled out
absolutely true
uh
i think that just about does it until i
was on the tonight show with terry
hatcher and i was knocked unconscious on
television
uh i think you all remember that
still a little loopy from that i'm
under the delusion that the tonight show
went away suddenly
it's all just a dream anyway those are
my grievous wounds i answered your
question i really bared my soul in more
ways than one hope you appreciate it if
you want to ask me a question just go to
facebook.com
teamcoco
and i'll tell you more we'll see you
then
[Music]
you